في السودان افاد مراسل الجزيره ان طائرات
الحربيه التابعه للجيش السوداني تواصل
التحليق في مدن العاصمه الخرطوم الثلاث
وذلك بعد معارك بالاسلحه الثقيله دارت امس
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع في المنطقه
الصناعيه بالعاصمه الخرطوم وشارع الغابه
وتستمر الحرائق لليوم الثالث على التوالي
في منشاه للنفط والغاز عقب هجوم على مجمع
اليرموك العسكري للصناعات الدفاعيه جنوبيه
العاصمه الخرطوم
اسامه سيد احمد ينضم الينا من شرق الخرطوم
اسامه
مواجهات البارحه وصفت بانها الاعنف بين
الدعم السريع والجيش في الخرطوم عما اسفرت
بحسب المعلومات التي وصلتكم
بالفعل
المواجهات العنيفه التي حدثت اول امس بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريعه في منطقه محيط
مجمع اليرموك لصناعات الدفاعيه التابعه
للجيش السوداني كانت هذه المواجهات بالفعل
وصفت بهم بانها الاعنف والاكثر حده ما بين
الطرفين منذ اندلاعي الحرب في الخامسه عشر
من ابريل الماضي هذه الحرب المستمره ولا
تزال تداعياتها طبعا مستمره منذ صباح
اليوم كانت هناك كثافه في تحليق الطيران
الحربي للجيش السوداني الذي حلق في سماء
واسعه من الخرطوم في الخرطوم والخرطوم
والخرطوم بحري وام درمان وكذلك طبعا
تلاحظون هذه الدخان اعمده الدخان التي
تتصاعد بشكل كثيف طبعا الدخان هذا الدخان
هو ما تبقى من الحرائق
طالت مستودعات الخزانات الوقود والغاز
هذه واحده من اكبر الخزانات في البلاد
للغاز والوقود وبالتالي هذه المنطقه كانت
تدور في محيطها معارك شرسه ما بين الطرفين
او الامس
ايضا في هذه المنطقه وليس بعيدا عنها يوجد
مجمع اليرموك لصناعات الدفاعيه التابعه
للجيش السوداني ايضا في محيطه شهدت هذه
المنطقه مواجهات عنيفه وصفت بالفعل انها
الاعنف منذ بدايه هذه الحرب الدخان الاخر
الذي يتصاحب ايضا من جهه اخرى يبدو انه في
منطقه الجنوب غرب منطقه المدينه الرياضيه
هذه المنطقه
منذ البدايه الاولى
للاندلاع هذه الح كانت مسرحا كبيرا
لمواجهات شرسه ما بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع فيما يبدو انها
متواصله او ربما تكون بقايا او تاثيرات
لمواجهات في هذه المنطقه او قصف مدفعي
من مدافع ثقيله نستمع ما بين الفيينه
والاخرى الى الدوي انفجارات في بعض
المواقع في جنوب وجنوب شرق الخرطوم وكذلك
في وسط الخرطوم ايضا كانت هناك عده
انفجارات متتاليه وكذلك ارتفعت اعمده
الدخان بشكل ليس بهذه الكثافه ولكن كانت
هناك اعمده الدخان ما يشير الى ان هذا
المكان ايضا كان مسرحا لمواجهات ما بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع طبعا
يحدث كل ذلك وسط يعني حياه يعيشها السكان
او ما تبقى من السكان هنا في ولايه
الخرطوم حياه انسانيه قاسيه للغايه وصلت
دعوات لطرفين بوقف اطلاق كامل حتى يعودوا
الى منازلهم التي اضطروا لمغادرتها خوفا
من هذه الحرب شكرا لك اسامه من شرق
الخرطوم